now to Bradley Cooper who just revealed
at the producers guild awards that his
wedding crashers past was a big reason
for his stars born future I first met
Toby 15 years ago on wedding crashers I
don't know what's good enemy today guys
15 years later I pitched him the fourth
remake of a film with a lead actress who
had never acted in a film or in director
who's never directed anything but he
trusted in me and Robert Downey jr.
thanked his Iron Man producer for taking
a career gamble back in 2008 so Kevin
Feige he medevacked me from the top of
insurance risk mountain he delivered me
to the upper middle of the forbes list
but i did this shoo shoo shoo
only et was backstage of the pga awards
with Emma Stone Jane Fonda and this
Gilmore Girls reunion Lauren Graham
presented Amy sherman-palladino
executive producer of the marvelous mrs.
nasal with the Norman Lear
achievement award I don't know what my
life would be without the biggest award
of the night went to Green Book
executive producer Octavia Spencer was
overcome with emotion I'm so humbled by
this and very emotional okay
[Music]